let's go
The Wedding Bells because Sophia Richie
just said I do to music exec Elliot
Grange I am so excited to be married
just because I'm marrying Elliot he's
like the man of my dreams so I'm so
excited now E.T is taking you inside
their big day are you the kind of girl
who dreams of your wedding uh yeah for
sure I've always dreamed of like what my
wedding would be like the couple tied
the knot in a lavish wedding ceremony on
Saturday in the south of France the
bride stunned in a beaded Chanel dress
with a halter neckline it was like
Larger than Life a dream to have a
Chanel wedding dress as for her
something blue I have actually on the
inside my something blue so it says ass
and E with the date underneath it and
Sophia she had not one not two but three
Chanel dresses for the wedding weekend
there are three dresses because there
are three events we have a rehearsal
dinner
we have my wedding dress and of course
the after party for the rehearsal the
model rocked this long-sleeved beaded
number it honestly fits like a glove I'm
scared to move because I don't want to
ruin one bead this is like a fairy tale
and when it came to her rehearsal
accessories Sophia's sister Nicole
Richie made her custom diamond earrings
I'm a very classy lady Nicole shared
these snaps with her little sis writing
that the experience was a moment she
will never forget Sophia whose dad is
Lionel Richie shared a few sneak peeks
at the actual wedding day on Instagram
including an epic fireworks show
and she followed tradition tossing her
bouquet to a group of gals
of course no wedding is complete without
an epic dance party and that's just what
Sophia did
[Applause]
so I have asked for the after party to
be somewhat like a nightclub very dark
fun music strobe lights I will be eating
pizza surprise in this dress pray for
this dress and yes that's dress number
three inspired by a dress supermodel
Claudia Schiffer wore in the 90s this to
me is like my little girl dream this
dress and the fact that it is inspired
off of Claudia schiffer's Runway look is
Iconic and dope I can dance I can move I
love it
of course the lovebirds tie the knot two
years after going public with their
romance great things are happening and
I'm really excited about it the pair got
engaged last year capturing the intimate
proposal on Instagram first of all it's
an awesome feeling at the time A source
told E.T the couple had been serious for
a while so their engagement was not a
big surprise to anyone I grew up with a
famous dad so I'm just kind of used to
the noise and yeah her famous dad gave
his stamp of approval too you know what
this is pretty fabulous family to me is
everything
ET Source says the whole fam's over the
moon adding that they're really happy
for her and think Elliot's a great guy
foreign